millions are under alerts for nasty
weather across the country including in
the South now this is just some of the
damage from a tornado that hit Ripley
Mississippi yesterday and there were
also suspected tornadoes elsewhere
including in Tennessee that's where Omar
villafranca is right now in the town of
Etheridge Omar good morning to you
good morning this storm packed quite a
punch you can see this little shopping
center behind me it got hit the front of
the building came off already but people
aren't wasting any time they already
have some tarp up now we did learn that
at least two people were hurt one person
in Tennessee and one in Mississippi and
the national weather service will be in
both states to survey the damage
I was on the phone with my husband and I
told him I said I got to get to the back
I said it's done here Linda Stagg says
she feels lucky to be alive after a
tornado ripped through Ethridge
Tennessee severely damaging this
building while she was inside working
that was
the back and I turned where I looked I
saw the front building moved she saw
insulation fly everywhere as she took
cover
this video shows a tornado touching down
in Smithville Mississippi one of three
reported in the state Thursday the
strong wind knocked down large trees
power lines and gas station pumps it got
really loud the wind picked up and then
it kept getting louder and louder Anna
Jordan says that when she looked outside
there was debris and damage everywhere
the garage is pretty much gone it pretty
much lifted the roof
to the north snow created dangerous near
whiteout conditions in Iowa and in
Wisconsin a semi-hauling cars jackknifed
on the interstate blocking traffic for
hours not a great drive not a great
drive very uh roads are not the best on
the campus of Northwestern University
this massive tree crashed to the ground
injuring four faculty members three were
rushed to the hospital at least one was
in critical condition
back here in Tennessee the 911 director
told us that this area is predominantly
Amish which means they don't use a lot
of Technology they don't have cell
phones and they don't use cell phones to
track storms but they did have a storm
siren nearby that was going off and the
officials are saying they're likely that
no one was seriously hurt Nate lucky
indeed Omar thank you